Oh Mars with us in Houston Texas hey
Omar how are you hey Dave how's it going
thanks for taking my call on my daily
listener well thank you how can I help
other question that my dad and I have
been weighing out for probably half a
year now I've been approved for uber I
have two cars that are paid off but
they're not within the year that they
require and I wanted to get your opinion
on getting a lease just to do uber to
supplement my income would that make
sense no no idea absolutely horrendous
idea so what are you two what are you
two cars worth uh I have a 2005 Dodge
Magnum I think Blue Book on it's
probably four or five thousand and I
just have an old pickup whatever right
uh probably a thousand is this a old
Ford Ranger what sobers requirement that
you have to have a car with in from
today's data has to be at least a two
thousand eight and under a hundred and
forty thousand miles you can't get one
of those for seven or eight thousand
dollars yeah but it was with my income
it would take me a year a year and a
half to save that up why if you sold
both your cars you'd have seven or eight
thousand dollars wouldn't you true
but I don't know if I would get a you
know what my cell price is for my my
vehicles well you mean that what is your
income I'll make about 50 a year
okay well what I would do is save up
some money to buy a car to go with the
two cars sell both cars put a little
money with it and buy a car if you're
wanting to do Ober that fits within the
guidelines yeah could I have to
supplement my income because I do odd
jobs on the side to pay my bills because
my whole 50 doesn't you know mine are
jobs either we do marketing for events
like what do you call it marketing
eblasts over the you know over the
Internet can you not make more of that
doing that than you do with Oprah
it's up and down in the closu it's not
well yeah yeah it is this so
inconsistent I've been doing it for
years and maybe you ought to use your
marketing prowess to do a better job
marketing your business to get more
marketing jobs you'll make more doing
that than you will with uber I'm not
against uber there's nothing wrong way
that it's not a bad way to make some
extra money but there is no way under
the Sun I would tell you to lease a car
to go in with uber there is so many
forces affecting that company right now
from the outside in that you don't you
know what if Houston passed a law that
may do buri illegal in one of the cities
that has attacked oberon regulations
then you're there you sit with a dadgum
lease payment to new I'm not going to
that game not a chance
I don't think that's going to happen by
the way and I'm not predicting the
downfall of uber but I'm not betting you
leasing a car on uber being successful
continually that's it knew not a chance
see the only way this day only way that
that theory makes sense is if everything
goes perfectly and there's one thing we
know about businesses it never goes
perfectly right so that's why your least
Theory leasing a card to Ober theory is
so weak because it is based on only the
idea that everything works just like
it's supposed to work and it never does
ever ever